in order to prevent global warming from
reaching 1.5 degrees it's estimated that
the next 10 years are crucial for us to
collaborate across sectors to remove and
prevent carbon pollution which is also
known as greenhouse gases
an incredibly interdisciplinary open
data project called climate trace is
presently led by 10 entities and former
vice president al gore and is
collaborating with over 50 organizations
to come together and help detect where
carbon pollution is presently coming
from by country and even by industry
using satellite images and machine
learning
soon it will transparently publish where
pollution arises from a particular
factory a coal plant an agricultural
field an animal farm etc
the intention behind creating this
global inventory of emissions is to help
policy makers industry operators and
even consumers who may not only be
investing in high polluting
organizations and take actions quickly
to prevent a climate crisis
because the energy sector is currently a
top focus in this episode we walk
through how to generate a geospatial
classification model that passes the
image of a coal power plant from a
satellite called sentinel-2 and tells us
whether that plant is on or off
[Music]
thanks to data today we can understand
our natural world with far greater
richness than ever before by orders of
magnitude this now empowers us to build
amazing apps that can help us solve
complex social and environmental
challenges and so in this series let's
build an app together
meet gavin who is executive director at
whattime which is a non-profit that
helps the public understand how clean is
the electricity i'm using right now
using technology historically it's been
challenging to measure this
the global state-of-the-art mostly is
self-reporting just asking emitters how
much they emit and in some cases having
extremely expensive on-site equipment at
individual power plants and factories a
couple of governments around the world
but very few have open power plant
monitoring
and they monitor their heaviest sources
of emissions and provide that data free
to the public
for most sources of emissions around the
world there is no equivalent system and
so it wasn't the case that we could just
add up all of the open data and process
that into a global emission system we
actually needed to go out and create the
emissions databases that we were
aggregating to have a sense of global
emissions
climatetrace's web app and dataset uses
publicly available satellite data from
earth engine as well as privately owned
data
and all the compute processing and
classifying of the 59 trillion bytes of
data from over 11 000 sensors that come
from hundreds of satellites is done on
google cloud by using products such as
tensorflow and vertex ai for training
and labeling data bigquery and earth
engine for data analysis and kubernetes
engine for container management just to
name a few
without google this project really would
have never happened we submitted a grant
application for what we thought was a
little bit of a pie in the sky moon shot
we thought if this worked it would be
amazing google took a really big bet on
a project back when it was just an idea
they gave us a generous 1.7 million
dollar grant to make the project
possible
and then they doubled down they said you
know what we really want this project to
succeed and we're going to send seven
engineers full time for six months to
help accelerate this team of scientists
to make sure the machine learning and
the data engineering really are
successful
they then further doubled down to
support the coalition as this project
matured growing from an initial idea
around power plants to the new climate
trace concept of monitoring all ghg
emissions
i am beyond oppressed and very proud by
this project and send a warm-hearted
shout out to all the volunteers and
organizations who have made this idea
become reality
for those of us equally interested in
working with ai and satellite imagery
let's go a bit deeper on how we could
approach this problem
let's start with understanding our
inputs and outputs
our input data comes from sentinel-2
which is a satellite owned by the
european space agency
multi-spectral images of the entire
planet are taken every 10 days since
2015.
every pixel in these images
approximately covers a 10 meter by 10
meter area
when working with satellite data each
input image has dimensions of width
height and bands
bands are measurements from specific
satellite instruments for different
ranges of the electromagnetic spectrum
for example sentinel 2 contains 13
spectral bands if you are familiar with
image classification problems you can
think of the bands similar to images as
red green blue rgb channels
however when working with satellite data
we generally have more than just three
bands
as for outputs in this example the
output is a single number between zero
off and one on representing the
probability of that coal plant being on
next let's move on to building a data
set
climate climatrice went through the
labor of love of labeling lat long
locations of coal plants that correspond
to sentinel 2 images and shared it as a
csv each coal plant's location is on or
off at different times
next we use earth engine to get the band
values for a patch of pixels given their
lat long timestamp and on or off label
from each row of the csv file
we basically view the band values as the
data and the label as the answer
from this we randomly split this data
into training and validation data sets
and save them as tf records in cloud
storage
for this case we split it into 70
training and 30 validation data sets
this means the model studies and learns
from the training data set
while the validation data set is used
like an exam to make sure it's learning
to generalize to data it hasn't seen
before
next we use vertex ai google's machine
learning platform to train and validate
the model
we use a convolutional neural network
which is an ml technique that works well
with image data
it receives a patch of pixels where the
power plant is at its center
and as a friendly note each pixel in
sentinel 2 is approximately 10 meters so
we decided to use a padding of 16 pixels
around the plant
that means that our 33 by 33 patch is
around
330 meters by 330 meters
because of this our training data is a
consistent patch of 33 by 33 pixels and
the model returns the probability of the
plant being on
once we're happy with our model it is
stored into cloud storage as well
and in order to use that model to make
predictions of coal plants we deploy it
on cloud run and make it a predictions
service
and when done we celebrate with a dance
party
[Music]
so what's next if you would like to
review this process in greater detail in
the description below i have included
the link to an interactive notebook with
all the code used to build a sample
written by nikita a super passionate
peer of mine you can also find a blog
post and several helpful resources too
and community i'll leave you with a fun
fact from gavin about the project before
we end and if you found this content
helpful you can subscribe or leave a
comment on other ai for good use cases
you may have in mind cheers one fun
surprise about this project is i didn't
know how much the satellites that orbit
the earth today are mostly designed for
maps so so that we can all drive where
we need to go nearly every satellite has
been designed to land at about 11am
overhead
problem is what if you're trying to see
the emissions of something that doesn't
happen at 11am we've had to call
increasingly obscure agencies around the
world of various countries that happen
sometime to launch a satellite that's
good at seeing things at night
and we've gotten to know just how many
satellites are designed to see things
right before noon
[Music]
you